une nouveauté qui réjouira tous les
pêcheurs la can a lancé qui projette
automatiquement la cuillère à 16 mètres
et qui permet de ne plus se soucier des
berges broussailleuse enfin on songe aux
trésors d'ingéniosité qu'il fallait
jusqu'ici déployé pour arriver à lancer
cette pauvre cuillère faut risquer
d'accrocher une branche au passage on
n'avait rien trouvé de mieux que le lens
fusée mais tout de même la méthode
sentait son bricole et puis il valait
mieux savoir nager
nantes a imaginé ce parapluie canne à
pêche qui tient compte des secousses du
cochon captifs
le clou du concours d'honneur le bouchon
atomique pour pêcheurs somnolent qu'ici
les veilles tout court
réveil également les armes yeux des
taquineurs de nos jours